I do have a sperm donor but you dill
yeah do you can I see a picture Tristan
oh my god yes you heard that right in
the latest episode of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians Chloe reveals she'd be
open to having another baby with extra
stand Thompson
despite their rocky past after my
doctor's appointment
I talked to Tristan because if you can
create embryos and do all the DNA
testing I do think that's the smarter
choice
Chloe's relationship with the Canadian
NBA star took a turn just days before
she gave birth to their daughter true in
2018 when reports surfaced that he had
cheated on her during her pregnancy the
two later reconciled but Chloe called it
quits for good after Tristan was accused
of cheating again the following year
this time with their sister Kylie
Jenner's best friend Jordan Woods which
is why Chloe says having another baby
with him would be strictly business he
has to sign like legal paperwork that he
would just be my sperm donor Wow it's
weird because Tristan and I were not
together I don't know which way to go